YouTube has a problem that I absolutely
hate which is drama I can't think of
anything more stupid to waste your time
on that's a tie now couldn't have been
more wrong I take it all back I changed
my mind
damn it what are people on YouTube want
more than anything creative original
content
now [ __ ] that they want views damn it
and I think you know where I'm going
with this
what gives views more than anything
that's right
drama YouTube has a problem that I
absolutely hate which is drama
how could I have been so wrong you know
I watched that video in disgust now you
probably seen some drama going on from
one youtuber to another hey I don't like
your I don't like you know oh I'm gonna
roast you and then they and then they
roast back and the views the views just
go back and forth like a tennis ball why
a tennis ball the monster
feeds itself listen me I aren't gonna
just start some pity drama with some
other shitty youtuber anyone can [ __ ]
do that okay I'm gonna start drama with
everyone all the youtubers you like [ __ ]
them I'm gonna make them feel so bad so
shitty that they're gonna they're gonna
make a pretty pie rant video hopefully
and then finally I'll be relevant here
we go
for three
one cinnamon toast can fat scarce feds
cry probably fine I'm not gonna have any
friends after this jacksepticeye Irish
[ __ ] rice cub North Korean [ __ ]
I'd use twenty five involving chaos I
triggered by anything
Rihanna VEVO ugly Dan and Phil are they
dating no we won't [ __ ] tell you
[ __ ] you you'll never know Edgar worst
[ __ ] dog
seananners I laugh at everything as long
as it gives reviews seananners I laugh
at anything to hide that I'm unfunny
Shane Dawson wishes he could come out
twice jacksFilms gay vibes taylor swift
ugly fouseytube worst channel on youtube
skydoesminecraft definitely still
enjoying minecraft dantdm definitely
still enjoying minecraft kick the pj
needs to be kicked
markiplier crybaby h3h3 too many chins
egoraptor too many chins leafy chin
implants think about it oh I could go
all night son I could go all night Emma
blackery more like Emma
boohoo my life is so hard to read Dylan
the hacker can't even [ __ ] hack Roman
Atwood quality content jenna Marbles
more like I am ten times hotter and of
all my profile pictures than and what I
really am keemstar he's a nice fellow
he's a nice fellow Lilly sings the
definition of trying too hard
filthy Frank I love him Billy Dee oh
yeah I've been on YouTube longer than
you so you can [ __ ] off toby turner drug
issue marina joyce drug
we said that what's that video game
junkie not black zoella the worst
content I've seen but still doing pretty
well it's pretty good
Casey nice - the only person on YouTube
with a bigger nose than I have
hey I'm boogie and I want to be
everyone's friend face clam almost as
relevant as Call of Duty syndicate made
the slimy asleep on YouTube that I have
ever seen and somehow still making
videos quibble [ __ ] head almost big as
ego Hillary Clinton dying YouTube dying
PewDiePie wish I once was that a good
was that a good exit I got him good
didn't I I can't wait for all the drama
I can't wait for all the views oh boy I
roasted them hard I'm just gonna sit
back here don't forget to check out my
patreon link it's in your description
thank you so much for watching leave a
like because all the fans are gonna hate
on me now so I need you to leave a like
to protect me and not just because I
want more likes okay